Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo, une nouvelle
vidéo avec
la petite caméra comme avant, là récemment j'ai beaucoup fait de vidéos
dans mon bureau
avec un plan fixe et je me suis dit pourquoi pas refaire une vidéo dans un
cadre différent
avec la petite caméra.
Alors aujourd'hui, je voulais parler d'un sujet qui, en anglais, ça se
traduirait comme
« you have to enjoy it ». En français, ça donnerait peut-être « il faut
prendre du
plaisir », « il faut faire ce qu'on veut », « il faut faire ce qu'on aime». Et bien
sûr ça en lien avec l'apprentissage des langues. J'avais envie de parler de
ce sujet
parce que souvent quand on va sur internet, il y a plein de vidéos, de
contenus qui nous
disent si vous voulez apprendre une langue, il faut faire comme ça, il faut
faire ça,
ça et ça. Et moi le premier, c'est-à-dire que dans mes vidéos, souvent je
dis il faut
faire de l'immersion, il faut faire de l'écoute, il faut lire, il faut
faire des flashcards,
il faut faire beaucoup d'immersion avant de faire de l'expression, donc
beaucoup d'input
avant de faire de l'output. Et voilà, moi aussi je fais ça parce que je dis
ça, je
propose ça sur ma propre expérience, mon apprentissage du japonais et je me
dis je
veux essayer de donner aux personnes qui apprennent le français les
meilleures façons pour
apprendre le français à partir de ma propre expérience. Et je pense que
tout le monde
fait ça parce que tout le monde est plus ou moins convaincu qu'il y a des
méthodes
plus ou moins efficaces et c'est vrai. Mais dans cette vidéo, je voulais
parler
de… il faut prendre du plaisir, il faut aimer ce qu'on fait, tout
simplement parce
que le plus important c'est d'avoir une habitude, c'est de faire un petit
peu tous
les jours, un petit peu régulièrement et surtout ne pas abandonner. Et je
vais parler
de ça parce que tout simplement, quand on fait quelque chose qu'on n'aime
pas vraiment,
quand on fait quelque chose seulement parce qu'on nous a dit qu'il fallait
faire comme
ça, souvent on arrête, on abandonne et c'est tout le sujet de cette vidéo.
Avant de commencer,
je voulais vous dire que j'ai ouvert un Patreon et il y a un lien dans la
description,
donc si vous voulez me soutenir, vous avez le lien et un énorme merci à
Gilad, j'espère
que je prononce bien, mais Gilad qui est mon premier soutien, donc un
énorme merci
à toi. L'idée de cette vidéo, ça m'est venue
avec mon apprentissage du Portugais. En octobre dernier, j'avais dit que je
voulais
apprendre le Portugais en trois mois, donc jusqu'à fin décembre, donc pour
pouvoir
fin décembre parler avec ma famille qui est portugaise. Bon, vous n'avez
pas vu de
vidéo sur cette chaine où je parle avec ma famille en Portugais, donc vous avez
sûrement
compris que je n'ai pas réussi, j'ai échoué, j'ai raté mon objectif, je
n'ai pas réussi
à atteindre mon objectif. Et je pense qu'en grande partie, ça vient du fait
que j'ai
essayé de faire des choses que finalement je n'ai pas vraiment aimé faire.
Je m'explique.
Comme j'avais une contrainte, comme je me suis dit il faut que j'apprenne
en trois
mois, c'est vraiment une contrainte de temps, je me suis dit mon
apprentissage doit être
le plus efficace possible. Ma seule expérience avant ça d'apprentissage
d'une langue
en autodidacte, donc apprendre une langue tout seul, c'était le japonais.
Et pour
le japonais, souvent les méthodologies c'est faire un maximum d'immersion
avant de faire
l'expression, essayer de consommer un maximum de contenu avant de pouvoir
commencer à parler.
Et c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire pour le portugais, j'ai commencé à
regarder
des vidéos, j'ai commencé à créer un maximum de cartes mémoires pour
booster ma compréhension
avant de passer à l'expression, avant de commencer à parler ou à écrire,
etc.
Et du coup, ce que j'ai commencé à faire par exemple, c'est faire des
cartes de mémoire
pour la conjugaison. J'ai demandé à Chat GPT, fais-moi des phrases pour
tous les verbes
importants en portugais, fais-moi une phrase pour chaque temps et pour
chaque pronom. Donc
vous savez en français par exemple on va avoir manger et on va dire je
mange tu manges
il mange nous mangeons vous mangez ils mangent. Mais là en fait j'ai dit à
Chat GPT
fais-moi une phrase pour chacune de ces conjugaisons je mange une pomme le
matin je mange tu
manges un kiwi le soir il mange des pâtes etc. Et du coup Chat GPT m'a
fait ça,
il m'a créé ces phrases et j'ai donc pu créer des cartes de mémoire avec
ça. Et
là déjà il y a eu un problème c'est que j'étais un peu dans une optique,
j'avais
un peu une vision d'eux, il faut que ce soit le plus efficace possible donc
je vais créer
un maximum de cartes pour apprendre le plus rapidement la conjugaison. Et
la première
erreur c'est que je pense que quand on fait ça, quand on crée beaucoup de
cartes d'un
coup, quand on crée beaucoup de cartes avec Chat GPT, des cartes
impersonnelles finalement
les phrases on ne les mémorise pas vraiment. Tout simplement parce que ce
n'est pas nos
phrases, c'est vraiment quelque chose qui a été créé par Chat GPT. Et du
coup
au début j'ai commencé à revoir des phrases sur la conjugaison et en fait
je ne me mémorisais
pas vraiment. Non seulement c'était ennuyant parce que ce n'était pas des
phrases que
j'avais particulièrement envie de dire, ces phrases n'avaient rien de
spécial pour
moi. Et deuxièmement c'était moins efficace pour la mémorisation tout
simplement parce
que ce n'était pas des phrases personnelles. Et du coup au bout d'un moment
j'ai juste
arrêté. Au début j'ai commencé à réviser ces cartes et peut-être au bout de
une ou
deux semaines j'ai commencé à me dire c'est ennuyant. C'est vraiment je ne
prends pas
de plaisir à essayer de mémoriser ça parce que c'est ennuyant. J'avais
envie d'éviter
le passage par écrire toutes les conjugaisons un peu chaque jour. Je vais
peut-être essayer
de faire ça mais en tout cas ce que j'ai fait pour que ce soit pour que je
prenne
plus de plaisir, pour que je fasse quelque chose que j'aime plus, c'est que
j'ai commencé
à utiliser, bon j'utilise Gemini mais bon c'est une intelligence
artificielle comme
Chat GPT. Et du coup ce que j'ai commencé à faire c'est plutôt faire
l'inverse c'est-à-dire
« Bonjour Gemini, j'ai envie de pouvoir parler portugais avec ma famille,
j'ai envie
de parler portugais avec toi, si je fais des erreurs, corrige mes phrases».
Bien évidemment
il m'a dit ok, il n'a pas pu me dire non je n'ai pas envie. Il m'a dit ok
et là
j'ai commencé à me dire « Demain si je parle avec ma famille, qu'est-ce que
je
dis ? ». Et je me suis dit « Je vais commencer par essayer de raconter mes
journées. Je
vais dire aujourd'hui je vais manger chez mes parents, on va manger ça, on
va peut-être
boire un peu de vin, etc. ». Et quand j'ai commencé à faire ça je me suis
dit « Comment
je le dis en portugais ? » Aujourd'hui je vais manger quelque chose. Et
rien qu'en
commençant comme ça j'ai commencé à me dire Comment on conjugue par
exemple « Allez
je vais manger. Ça c'est le futur proche « Je vais manger quelque chose
». Le portugais
c'est très similaire au français c'est une langue latine donc forcément ça
va avoir
une forme très similaire. Et en portugais on dit « Eu vou comer"
quelque chose comme ça. Ma prononciation est encore très mauvaise.
Et du coup avec
cette démarche de commencer finalement avec un peu de l'expression écrite
j'ai commencé
à me poser des questions « Comment est-ce qu'on conjugue ce verbe ? Comment
est-ce que
je peux dire cette phrase ? ». Et en faisant un peu le chemin inverse
finalement j'ai
commencé à créer des phrases avec des conjugaisons basiques parce qu'au
début on est forcément
obligé d'utiliser des conjugaisons basiques. Et du coup Gemini a commencé à
me dire
« Ah pour aller en portugais c'est le verbe ir et ça se conjugue comme ça.
» Donc tu
peux dire « Eu vou, Ele va etc., etc. » Ma prononciation est encore
très mauvaise
tout simplement parce que je n'ai pas commencé à parler portugais. Mais je
vais revenir
là-dessus. Et du coup rien qu'en faisant cette démarche qui est peut-être,
qui à
première vue paraît moins efficace, c'est moins rationnel on va dire,
c'est moins
j'apprends une liste, j'apprends les 700 mots les plus courants,
j'apprends
les 700 mots les plus fréquents. Comme ça je vais optimiser mon temps
d'apprentissage.
Et bien finalement non seulement le matin j'ai envie de le faire parce que
ça m'intéresse,
je me projette, ça me donne envie de pouvoir parler avec ma famille. Et ça
me fait finalement
travailler la conjugaison et je mémorise mieux tout simplement parce que
j'applique
directement ces conjugaisons. Je les applique dans un cadre dans lequel je
me projette,
dans une situation où je me projette. Il y a une pratique peut-être que
vous le faites
en français, mais il y a une pratique qui est assez intéressante je trouve,
c'est
quand vous, dans votre tête, vous vous imaginez être interviewé par
quelqu'un en français
par exemple. Imaginez que vous êtes devant moi, on fait un podcast en
français.
En parlant lentement et je vous pose plein de questions sur votre vie. Et
là directement
vous allez commencer à réfléchir en français, à vouloir dire je suis
américain, je suis
né à Chicago, pourquoi est-ce que tu apprends le français ? J'apprends le
français parce
que etc. Et en fait quand on se met dans ces situations, on se projette
beaucoup plus
pour parler la langue et ça c'est assez intéressant je trouve. Je le fais
parfois
en anglais et j'ai commencé à le faire en japonais. Et là je vais faire une
parenthèse
en fait. Je pense que l'erreur que j'ai fait avec le portugais c'est de
vouloir faire
comme pour mon apprentissage du japonais. Et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que comme
les langues sont complètement différentes, ça demande une approche
différente. C'est-à-dire
que je ne vais pas aimer faire la même chose en portugais qu'en japonais.
Le japonais
au début c'est très difficile à comprendre parce que la structure des
phrases est très
différente, les mots sont très différents et en fait je pense que j'ai aimé
faire beaucoup
d'immersion tout simplement parce que j'avais l'impression de déchiffrer un
code. J'avais
l'impression de vraiment essayer de comprendre quelque chose de très
difficile. Alors qu'en
portugais c'est devenu très vite ennuyant parce que comme c'est très
similaire aux
français je me disais en fait à part quelques mots que je ne comprends pas,
en général
j'arrive quand même à comprendre. Et du coup l'immersion était un peu
ennuyante
pas parce que c'était trop facile mais parce que je n'avais pas
l'impression
de progresser vers mon but, vers mon objectif. Et ça je pense qu'il faut se
poser la question
de les langues sont très différentes et donc forcément on ne peut pas faire
appliquer
la même méthode pour toutes les langues. Et du coup vraiment se poser la
question de
qu'est-ce que j'aime faire, qu'est-ce que j'aimerais faire et qu'est-ce que
quand
j'étudie cette langue, qu'est-ce que j'aime faire ? Et du coup pour le
portugais j'ai
maintenant j'écris avec Gémini, j'essaye de lui raconter un peu mes
journées en écrivant
seulement et je vais revenir là-dessus. Et en même temps je lis un livre,
j'ai lu
donc le premier Harry Potter avec ma liseuse Kindle et là je lis "Mémoire
d'une Gaïsha"
qui est un livre que j'avais beaucoup aimé en français et là rien que de le
lire en
portugais le soir. Vraiment j'ai pas l'impression de travailler. Ce n'est
pas un apprentissage
vraiment efficace parce que je ne cherche pas à comprendre à ce verbe et à
quel temps,
quelle conjugaison on sait etc. Mais en tout cas je passe du temps à faire
de l'immersion
et ça c'est important. Je reviens juste sur la raison pour laquelle pour
l'instant
je ne fais que écrire avec Gémini, je ne parle pas encore portugais, tout
simplement parce
que j'ai envie d'avoir une bonne prononciation. Ça va être difficile de
parler couramment,
d'avoir un accent fluent mais j'ai vraiment envie de travailler cet aspect
de la langue,
la prononciation. Ce n'est pas quelque chose que j'ai vraiment fait en
japonais parce
que la prononciation est plus facile on va dire et il y a d'autres
difficultés. Mais
pour le portugais, j'ai vraiment envie de faire ça et du coup je pense
qu'il faut quand
même que j'écoute un maximum de portugais avant de commencer à parler. J'ai
commencé
aussi à essayer de faire un peu du shadowing, donc à prendre des phrases
spécifiques et
à essayer de les prononcer le mieux possible en m'enregistrant, notamment
avec la chaîne
Portuguese with Leo. Et ça, je pense que pour le portugais, je vois vraiment
une amélioration
et donc j'ai vraiment envie de travailler ça avant de commencer à faire de
l'expression.
Donc ma recommandation, c'est d'essayer quand même de faire beaucoup
d'écoute
avant de parler mais encore une fois, c'est une recommandation et si vous
voulez commencer
à parler, commencer à parler, si ça vous fait plaisir, commencer à parler,
ça sera
toujours de la pratique. Oui, vous allez peut-être prendre des mauvaises
habitudes
mais au pire, vous corrigerez ça plus tard et avoir un accent dans la
langue qu'on parle,
ça a son charme, ce n'est pas quelque chose de mauvais, je pense. Et du
coup voilà,
je pense que quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le portugais, je suis parti un
peu avec une
fausse idée, avec un peu cette envie de faire quelque chose de très
logique, de très rationnel
pour optimiser mon apprentissage et au final, j'ai juste abandonné, enfin
je n'ai pas
vraiment abandonné mais disons que quand j'ai commencé à travailler un peu
tous les jours,
après j'ai commencé à faire une ou deux fois par semaine seulement et
forcément je n'ai pas
progressé. Et du coup, là en changeant un peu ma méthode, je me suis rendu
compte que le matin,
j'ai plus envie d'aller sur Gemini et d'essayer de parler un peu portugais.
Bien évidemment,
j'essaye de pratiquer la conjugaison, c'est-à-dire que quand je fais des
phrases, j'essaye de dire
je, tu, il, nous, vous, etc. J'essaye un peu de varier parce que si vous ne
faites que parler en
utilisant "je", vous n'allez pas connaître les autres conjugaisons. Donc il
faut garder un peu en
tête la théorie, mais après c'est vraiment essayer de faire ce qu'il nous
plaît. Et
toute façon, quand vous allez vous exprimer, quand vous allez essayer de
parler ou de faire
quelque chose que vous aimez, quand vous allez imaginer faire un podcast
avec moi en français,
très rapidement, vous allez vous dire comment on dit ça en français,
comment on dit "I can
something". En français, c'est le verbe pouvoir. Je peux manger épicé par
exemple. Et quand vous
allez trouver des moyens de dire ce que vous voulez dire, vous allez
beaucoup mieux
mémoriser. Et c'est ce que j'essaye par exemple de faire avec mes étudiants
en classe, c'est-à-dire
que j'essaye de leur parler de sujets personnels. Je leur pose des
questions sur leur vie, sur ce
qu'ils aiment faire, etc. Je suis un peu en mode détective enquête de
police, mais je pense que
c'est, finalement, c'est le plus agréable et pour mémoriser, c'est assez
efficace. Si vous faites
une phrase où vous parlez de vos parents, où vous parlez d'une situation
que vous avez vécu,
vous allez mieux vous en rappeler. Donc voilà, un peu la morale de cette
vidéo, c'est un peu,
c'est pas vraiment le bon mot, mais la morale, c'est plus de ne pas oublier
de prendre du plaisir,
de ne pas oublier de faire ce que vous aimez, que ce soit pour l'immersion,
que ce soit pour
l'expression, faire ce qu'on veut pour prendre du plaisir et continuer de
progresser dans la langue.
Je pense que c'est le plus important et que parfois, quand on passe un peu
dans cet état d'esprit de
« je veux être fluent dans un an », finalement, on oublie un peu l'objectif
principal et on oublie
de prendre du plaisir et souvent on finit juste par abandonner. Et sur
Internet, il y a beaucoup de
contenus comme ça. J'ai fait un reel récemment où justement, je montre une
vidéo où c'est une
personne qui montre une appli d'apprentissage de langue et qui dit qu'elle
a appris le japonais
en un mois. En gros, ça, je trouve que c'est des contenus, en fait, c'est
de la publicité pour une
application et ça, ça génère juste de la frustration. On se met un peu dans
un mode « c'est
la course, il faut que j'arrive le premier, il faut que je réussisse le
premier », alors que
finalement apprendre une langue, ce n'est pas une course, c'est plus un
marathon, c'est un voyage et
il faut profiter un peu du voyage sinon on arrête tout simplement. Donc
voilà, j'espère que vous
aurez aimé un peu ce retour aux vidéos un peu sans script, un peu
brouillon et avec la petite
caméra dans un décor différent. J'ai d'autres formes vidéo que j'ai envie
d'essayer, que je vais
poster la semaine prochaine. Il y a une vidéo sur l'histoire des Daft Punk,
donc j'espère que ça
va vous plaire. Et après, j'ai envie d'essayer de faire des vidéos sur
l'actualité, donc prendre
un sujet d'actualité, expliquer factuellement l'actualité et dans un
deuxième temps, faire une
vidéo un peu comme ça où je donne mon opinion sur l'actualité pour qu'on
puisse échanger. Je pense
que ça peut être des formats intéressants. Sur les dernières vidéos, les
statistiques étaient
moins bonnes, donc je ne sais pas si c'est le cadre, le sujet. Dans tous les
cas, je vais continuer de
varier un peu le style des vidéos, donc n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous
aimez, ce que vous avez
aimé, etc. Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout et du coup je vous dis à
lundi pour une prochaine vidéo.